good afternoon everybody whoo-hoo this
is sort of weird with the long I think I
gotta say so who's among go developer
uses [ __ ] on a regular basis couple
people and other no sequel databases
like CouchDB or stuff like that and in
the bizarro graph databases which I
shouldn't call bizarro cuz they're
really cool but I don't use them okay
and so presumably all know enough python
that this is not going to be completely
baffling this is not like your first day
of Python um in addition to working for
the capital one I'm also a writer for
packed books so I have a bunch of books
0 of which are about no sequel databases
so these are all you know basically just
straight-up Python no apologies so what
I want to talk about is what a schema
really is and why we need it you know
what's important are the ways we have to
represent a schema and in particular in
the nose schema database world you've
got two fundamental choices code because
after all Python as a descriptive kind
of dsl sort of thing for data is
fabulous so why not use that plus
there's the additional not code ways to
represent metadata and we'll look at
those two because it there's not one
size that fits all perfectly well size 9
good for me may not be good for you I'm
going to talk about some real code code
I mean we're looking a Python metaclass
which may be a little advanced for some
people but it works really well for me
so I'm happy with it and then I'm going
to talk a little bit about one of the
more complex problems in no sequel
database world is I have to make a
change to the schema that is not
backwards compatible the data or
something the app will break
fatally if I don't do this correctly and
this applies even to csv files because
after all how much schema information is
in a CSV file maybe the first row has
headings and that's it sometimes you
want a little more than just headings
and of course the worst case your CSV
file has no headings it's just pure data
and then it's like oh is this one
latitude or longitude uh uh uh I look
like numbers to me ones negative so I'm
guessing that's probably latitude go be
anything so I want to see my and and why
am I stuck with it uh what happens in
the sequel world is that there is a very
formal carefully thought through idea
dating from the nineteen and 60s all of
you are too young to remember that era I
was there and it was I I'm not have a
[ __ ] on my lawn in my chair insane i
just did your children too but what
happens is in the early days um they
divided the world into three bits that
was the user bed thing and how that's so
cool um so that song so let's just go
back so there's you know this user view
or externalized view there's the logical
or the conceptual model terminology
varies a little bit and then there's a
physical implementation model and in
tools like ur win when you apply column
data types they call that a physical
model it's not it's a logical model with
column data types it's garbage the
physical model is like Oracle
tablespaces in db2 whatever it is db2
stores your data in its physical it's
where it sits on the disk file system
stuff so the Sun fee is that there's
semen in their schema when you go to
look at the data this stuff you know or
might know for hope you know about the
data that isn't represented anywhere
there could be a company policy or some
other foolishness that influences very
deeply what this data might be
and I don't see that written down in any
sequel anywhere of course derived data
okay which is a violation a third normal
form but let me call anybody bad for
doing that happens all the time we got
tons of derived data calculating things
in there and not normalized l plus the
the star schema versus transaction
normalization and things like that so
don't get too involved in thinking that
the schema is everything because it's
it's several things all kind of
collected together conceptually in one
bucket ultimately in no sequel world the
user schema what the user thinks they
see and the logical schemas in the
database have been merged together into
one thing the document data structure
much simpler the physical schema is
generally something that is completely
invisible to you and with the good
databases like [ __ ] and couch you have
no idea how that's physically
represented on disk and you're happy
never to know you didn't want to know so
sequel world is somewhat simpler but
what's important is that in the no
sequel world it didn't simply vanish it
is still totally there it just doesn't
happen to be in your face all the time
and so you have to manage the thing so
no sequel gives us some flexibility that
sequel didn't really have but both have
a schema and so then the subtle question
sometimes becomes so what was the big
win why did I give up a sequel database
what am I getting out of this and the
funny thing about the sequel database is
that your schema exists in a variety of
places and it really does exist in a
variety of places you create table
statements some internal representation
in the database in your code your sequel
code and the schema is reflected in your
non-sequel code too and don't let
anybody lie to you about that well you
know i write this java that's super
clean and never reflects any aspect of
the schema it's using the columns is it
not is it not using the columns then it
reflects the schema in some sense so
don't tell
your coldness independent of any schema
that's stupid we'll come back to this so
if the scheme is not right or you don't
understand the schema or there's some
weird mismatch between the schema as
defined on a piece of paper and the
schema is represented in the database
you wind up with queries that do full
table scans and cartesian products this
is all sort of normal awfulness that
happens you can have application
programs that don't work because it gets
weird sequel errors that that's not a
date I didn't know it had to be a date I
thought it was a string somebody lied to
me select statements that don't work as
advertised we all will I've seen that
kind of thing and it gets worse because
if the schemas don't all line up right
then we're having to wait around while
app devs and database devs all not talk
to each other because they were busy
that week or there was a production
problem and they're still not busy they
won't talk to me anyway and stuff like
that what we do a lot of times is we
make it just a bare minimum schema
enough to make it work and nothing more
so that we don't have to deal with this
problem which is why we then switch to a
no sequel database so that the schema
are all merged together and we don't
have to deal with this problem either a
different way of not dealing with it we
can add extra layers to to try to close
the gap between the DML statements in
our code and the define schema which oh
by the way is yet another representation
of the scheme of bringing us up to a
total of five copies of the full thing
so here's what I want to talk about in
Python world in a no sequel database
where there is not a official schema but
there still is a schema conceptually
you've got to have an idea what the data
looks like I want to have a defined
schema I want to have a defined schema
into code because code is cool I don't
want to have it somewhere else floating
around in the database where I can't
find it very easily I want to have it if
possible stated exactly once so that
there's no real mystery about what's
going on and so I'll show you three
techniques that I think get you to this
world so the first thing is the schema
representation ensure that we have
figure out
we want to write down I have two broad
categories of things we can write
scheming down as pure um code white
Python or we can have some separate
metadata may be hidden in the code after
all python is triple quoted strings I
can put giant amounts of data inside a
Python file and then maybe parse it
separately not saying I haven't done
that more than once I can put in
separate class I can actually put it in
a [ __ ] collection why not if I'm
careful about my schema I can actually
put it in the database and the program
fetch the full thing I'm gonna advertise
up front that this is sort of where I'd
like to head and so the idea of cleanly
separate metadata still embedded in the
code makes me very happy because now we
know where to look for everything one
github repo it's all there how much
better can it be so here's the ad hoc
pure code thing I have yes this is
undesirable I've got served what amounts
to schema information because I you know
I made a connection to the database I
opened some um collection in that
database i did find and now I'm
mentioning a column name that I insert
implicitly i'm 'sorry this must exist in
every row should it fail to exist we die
in a key demo and that's unpleasant
makes me very unhappy cuz at three
o'clock in the morning Chris calls me up
and says state the database died Chris
I'm not sober hey you know it's just
this is just full an ha implied schema
documented know where you got to
basically search for every variable
under hood which appears to be a
instance of a collection to figure out
what the implied skimming is and and
that is dude so what they do a lot of
times for this pure code thing is
they'll define a class and you'll have a
in between some what [ __ ] uses
internally these on documents and your
application objects and that's not so
bad there's a Java version of that will
skip over Java for now so there's you
know I'm on go engine and there's [ __ ]
Kent and some other kinds of things that
we can use they're remarkably simple and
they're not exactly like object
relational mapping because in object
relational mapping your relational
database has to imply structure through
this bizarre deranged insane scheme
called foreign keys and so you have
multiple tables that are somehow but
literally collated together by virtue of
some key relationship or something I
don't even know anymore I'm too old to
remember that now and that some object
relational mapping in the relational
world I'm trying to reconstruct an
object from stuff that's in multiple
tables with multiple key relationships
craziness here the documents already
structured very clean and simple mapping
between a database documented in no
sequel database and a Python structure
thank goodness so here's the [ __ ]
engine example you know I create some
class of some defined thing from [ __ ]
engine and I define my fields and things
like that there will be an implicit save
method that comes along for the ride and
the save method persists things in the
database this is really really elegant
there's not too much bad to be said
about this but I think we can do a
little better and the reason I think we
can do a little better is this involves
a certain amount of overhead in mapping
between mongos internal data structures
and Python sort of implying date
structures in these class definitions
and it's just a layer of fuzziness that
isn't really helpful just sort of slows
things down a little
the information about the connection to
the database doesn't live in this
defiant class of all when you open up on
my go engine to use the full thing then
you'll say I want to get one of these
classes out of this collection to find
our whole lot persist something the same
has a way to map into its visit a
collection the longer did this yes yeah
they're done separately and the
different ones [ __ ] kidney other things
they all have slightly different ways of
handling this exact problem because it's
an anointing problem thank you only this
Mike thank you ok so my preference is
schema as separate kind of metadata
there's two common representations for
this the xml schema definition x SD
which is worthy and ex-mla and kind of
lulu xml so i would much prefer Jason
because Jason looks like Python or
Python looks like JSON I don't know
which came first chickens eggs whatever
I mean it's JavaScript notation but give
me a break somebody was reading off
somebody else's playbook when they
decided that a dictionary in Python
would look almost exactly like a
dictionary in JavaScript and and
therefore we have a pleasant symmetry
here so there's a whole JSON schema
organization everybody here familiar
with swagger specifications nobody
nobody good good that's ok it's ok you
don't be embarrassed but if you know
what the swagger specifications are then
you know a little bit about the JSON
schema org because that is the colonel
underneath swagger specifications and so
there's a Python package that I really
like the JSON schema package that
implements a validator for Jason schema
documents which is sort of the backbone
for validating swagger documents so
here's the three places that you could
conceivably put schema information I
think all three of these have certain
advantages and I've used them randomly
and so different people in different
projects say well I thought it was
better to yet that was thursday was
better today's Friday so
hey we're putting it in this game up in
the collection in the database yeah but
last Wednesday you said we could put in
an external JSON file you sure can enjoy
that was last Wednesday today it's not
wednesday anymore so um the idea of
having schema as a big old actual
literal Python dictionary no parsing no
funny business you write the thing out
um essentially no overhead it's just a
dictionary in a class definition and
other ones where you have like an
external file that you have to read or
you have to go find the full thing in a
collection in the database these are
touchy because there's a kind of an
overhead and so you gotta fetch the full
thing with some cleverness you only
fetch it once but you know it's work the
cost is nonzero so recap in the middle
no sequel doesn't mean no schema you
always have a schema it's the ad hoc
schema schema implied in code that is a
very bad idea vbi three letter acronym
easy to remember very bad idea no sequel
lets us have just a saddle schema I
think we should always try to put it in
the code I think the JSON schema is the
right way to do business I'm not a
hundred percent sure that the Mongol
engine schema as class definition is any
better I think the JSON schema has a few
tiny advantages so we'll move on to oh
that that's sort of internal stuff if
your happen to be here uh in our
internal github I have a thing that will
convert back and forth from Java to JSON
and Python and this and that it'll
generate Java code from json schema and
stuff who cares get on to the good stuff
so use cases the things we need to do
design and modeling time we got to get
to the point where we can get an idea
into code and you don't just sit down
and wipe that on a whiteboard because
that writing the design down on a
whiteboard and commencing to code is
death waiting to happen because whatever
you wrote down in that whiteboard may
have some performance question that you
didn't answer or worse yet you answered
it really glib
of course this will be fast says who but
of course it's obvious obvious this I
paint Lee why are you so dense this will
be fast run like lightning and then you
know you load up some data and perhaps a
little overly glib on the fast part
about that so my we'll talk data
validation checking a document before
you save in the database mmm manga
imposes of course no constraints at all
so you can have a collection of random
garbage each document in that collection
a unique creative work of art a
statement from my very soul unique
handcrafted artisanal data
artisanal drinks made from bourbon are
one thing you consume them and the night
vanishes you wake up on Sunday with an
uber bill you can't imagine in a place
in Delaware you didn't know existed
during how did I get an uber all the way
to delaware didn't think delaware was a
state having doubts now so schema did a
validation with some level of formality
in a no sequel database I think has
advantages and I think that anything you
can do to get a sense of what all those
documents are supposed to be is worth
its weight in gold which is how I got
started on this whole thing in the first
place how do we validate what's in the
database before it gets into the
database before I wake up in Delaware
and then the schema migration which is a
fairly difficult thing but we want to
confirm the collection is what we
thought it was going to be make whatever
non backwards compatible transformation
we're going to make document by document
until it's ready for the new version 4.0
of our app and then maybe just check it
after the change to make sure every
single document is really compatible
with a four-point-oh version of my app
because the worst thing that you could
do then is turn the old API on live
you've done the feature toggle and the
green version all crashes in flames so
that that would be a lot of bad things
can happen if you don't do this well so
my idea is that you really ought to
commit the design to a schema fairly
slowly and in particular with Python you
have the unique ability to basically
build technology spikes left right and
center let's model it like this okay
let's actually write the damn documents
pardon my french let's write the
documents let's put them in the database
let's fetch them out of the database
let's simulate a volume and say what are
we going to have a million of them two
million of them I think I can write a
for loop for I in range 1 million
and generate random data and built
documents as stuff in the database and
we'll see what happens you do your silly
find and you're aggregating whatever
your other aggregation was and the
aggregation you couldn't explain we will
write one and we'll see what it does oh
that wouldn't takes 15 minutes I guess
maybe we need some indexes or maybe we
need a completely different data
structure so that the aggregation
actually works in a finite amount of
time these are discussions you should
have early and often and Python gives
you unique ability to in a few minutes
bang out an example and say well here it
is and it doesn't work or here it is it
works great tweak the scripts until they
work you can even use them for
performance testing whatever you use to
generate a million random rose you can
continue that right on through to
production time and and when you have
the new version in the version for point
with a version 5.0 your random native
scrambler ought to still work and then
once it's gotten to the point where you
have some confidence in it ok now I'm
going to write a formal schema make a
swagger specification out of it builds
an AP is and we'll go on to the
interesting coding part that we
generally delegate to somebody else
because as scientists we generally don't
do all the coding we make programmers do
that that's me and so it would be nice
to have had this conversation sort of in
an offline mode as opposed to just
random mode do we can build prototypes
and look at them and then we can create
code that works because we have had a
chance to dry run the whole thing a
little bit as far as data validation is
concerned this is my nirvana end state
script that I have some data coming in
value value value whatever the values
are however i got them reading csv files
or whatever the heck happened to those
things i want to build an instance of a
class and if that instance cannot be
built because it violates some
definition in the schema I want it to
raise an exception and that's the end of
that so then we can you know do whatever
it is print out an error or something
like that a return of 404 or something
whatever if it's a webapp I don't I
don't know if I can build an instance of
the class then I'm happy inserting at
the database if I can't build an
instance of the class I should do
nothing more
and I like this as the objective this is
where we want to go to and what simple
programming like this the question
occasionally comes up shouldn't we use
an if statement to determine if it's
valid and the answer is raising
exceptions like this is faster than
writing if statements the exception
handling and python is fast if
statements are not as fast so just do it
like this here's the other one overall
scheme of validation for some object in
my database collection but try to build
the internal class representation of
that object if it works it's compliant
with the schema that's part of that
class if it doesn't work then the object
the document you got out of the database
can't be used to build the internal
Python representation of it something's
wrong with the database or something's
wrong with a schema you tell me I really
don't know how the database got never
that condition so now you're gonna have
to look at that document to find out who
touched that last and why did they touch
it manually Chris was three o'clock in
the morning and it needed to get up and
running and it was just a date just the
once we're a bank so that never actually
happens but we talk about what if like
it might happen but you know actual
production data there's so many eyeballs
watching you looking at the production
data that you know we laugh about what
if it gets tweaked and generally you get
kind of intellectually lazy because it
sort of can't be it would take a million
people to go tweet production data
invalidly what more often happens is i
broke a unit test and fudged the answer
and we got on and went into production
and some rows went in with something
that didn't actually pass the unit tests
correctly which is the same thing as
tweaking it manually because i fudged
something okay so what's really involved
in getting those two blocks of code to
work nicely I'm going to define a class
in Python it is going to implement some
basic crud rules create retrieve update
and delete the inn in [ __ ] those are
insert one find one replace
one and delete one so I have the
canonical Craig rules and we can look at
a class that will do all of this but
pretty elegantly there's a tricky part
[ __ ] has an update that is really
clever in what it can do inside the
database the problem is that it's
difficult to figure out how to make a
series of property changes to an
instance of a class into the sequence of
commands to update that object in [ __ ]
and so for people who are not [ __ ]
programmers it's like what and for the
people who are [ __ ] programmers it's
like you have to use update one so we'll
leave the tricky part out for now so
here's a the superclass for all of these
things that is defines my model this is
all the code there is almost by the way
it's this short so we're using built-in
features of [ __ ] the beasts on sun
class it's their version of JSON when
you see the documents they're
represented JSON when they're in the
database they're actually in a binary
version of JSON they call BS on and the
beasts on a library that you get with
pie [ __ ] handles that conversion
seamlessly between database binary and
the JSON you expect to see so that's a
lovely thing i'm just going to build on
it i'm not going to invent anything new
that i'm lazy that way the metaclass
we'll come back to in a sec the schema
itself is just a big old dictionary
schema title description blablablablabla
version collection nothing special to it
it's a JSON schema document literally
encoded as a dictionary their two little
extensions that I want to talk about the
version of the collection they're not
not anything too interesting instance
validation is a line of code this I'm
going to use the JSON schema library I'm
going to have it do its validate thing
on the object if it is all valid we're
good nothing else happens silently
succeeds love it if it's not valid and
breaks any of the scheme
definition rules big old exception is
thrown and I can't create an instance of
the object because it's invalid and this
is the fact that I need to write one
line of code to implement things i'm
loving that and then there's some
malarkey down here to dump the class out
in a kind of a generic way doesn't
involve too much serious Python magic
just kind of looks long and wordy but
you can get the code off github and and
play with it a little bit so the key
value proposition is it's all just an
internal beasts on document a thing pi
[ __ ] gave me that I did just wrapped a
little bit of stuff around my life is
very simple and the other part of it is
that I mean that reduces the
serialization overhead considerably it
also means that the JSON schema that is
in that class definition can become part
of my swagger specification by a simple
oh it's the schema object inside the
class and put it here in the swagger
document put this one here in the
swagger document and it involves no real
thinking to make sure that the swagger
document actually reflects the
implementation directly no mysteries and
for those of you who are serious Python
gurus this is the medic class I actually
build three internal class level of
variables the collection name the
MongoDB collection comes out of the
schema using the extension the version
comes out of the schema using the X
version extension and the Python doc
string is the schema description that
was in the JSON schema so you don't
actually write a doc string for the
class I make a doc string for the class
and that way the schema definition doc
string is the class doc string no
confusion everything is all in exactly
one place we just have two references to
it so here's what it would look like so
here's my resource class for random
resource that is something that is
dimensional model or I don't know what
it is something that we got from credit
card data or something and so you know
you write out the title because JSON
schema documents usually have titles and
we write a description that is the JSON
schema description
x version because this is version 1 and
we write the X collection the [ __ ]
collection we want it to be in almost
all of these things are of type object
there's a bunch of properties and
there's some required properties and the
required is part of the validation rules
that's imposed on this and then in the
small font that you can barely read
there's IDs and resource names and
resource other things and statuses and
approvers I don't even know what all's
going on in there and it's got a nested
object and an array of items all kinds
of malarkey going on holy cow is great
stuff um the really interesting bit very
small fun a pattern just you know a
thing that is used for data validation
that if this stray does not follow that
regular expression pattern then
validation error and it happens all in
the JSON schema thing by and run any
code to make that happen I only to write
it once in the definition of what i
expect the record for the documents to
look look so the object lifecycle is I'm
going to define a class that has the
schema I'm going to create documents
that are instances of that class if I
fail to create the document then that
attempted document creation violated a
constraint to find in the JSON schema
and I can stuff things into the
collection i can use [ __ ] pretty
directly without having to think about
it because the documents are already in
mongos preferred beasts on notation no
extra overheads my life is much simpler
the really tricky bit year schema
migration generally the whole point
about this is as we go forward from
version 1.04 to version 2.01 how do we
do this there's a couple of things we
can do we can coexist or we can do a
conversion coexistence means that we'll
have just two different collections with
two different collection names this is
just a [ __ ] technique that works well
we're not all [ __ ] people so who cares
schema migration is the interesting one
I've got all these documents in my
database that I want to claim work
for the version one schema I want to
convert them to the version 2 schema
save them in a new collection and then I
want to validate the version 2 schema
and say yes it really is correct every
one of those documents works against the
new schema definition and you'll notice
that I call them you know o1 and o2 and
everything's a no one and an 02 and you
want to put that right in the class
names in front of God and everybody that
this is the version 1 class definition
this is the version to class definition
you're not going to modify a class
you're going to introduce a new class
and they're going to live side by side
at least for the duration to this and
possibly longer because you may have
legacy data that you're doing some
analytics on and newer data that you're
doing ever so slightly different
analytics on because the schemas are
different and so you have both class
definitions in that way it's very clear
that this is the version 1 data and this
is the version 2 data and the version 1
data doesn't have the geolocation but
the version 2 does in the version 1 we
approximate geolocation using the zip
code into the version 2 we have the
actual number and we can kind of combine
them knowing that there's a huge error
in the version one day nobody need for
what your model doesn't know might work
and there's a way to handle downtime
with blue screen modification so it may
be a no sequel database but you still
have a schema you cannot escape that
sort of law of the land because it's at
least in your code in the way you deal
with the database so I figure as long as
it's going to be in your code put it in
the code for real right a JSON schema
document put it in a class definition
use it to validate instances the class
use it to validate documents in the
database we use it for as much as you
can prior to any insert or replace
before and after major database
migration changes it's uh it saves you
lots and lots of agony questions yes
if I was not using [ __ ] I would still
leverage the beasts on depending on the
complexity my documents if they truly
are nested eunos documents with sub
documents and a raise of sub documents
all not in any normal form I would still
use the base on thing pymongo is pretty
cool and the beasts on class definition
works really nicely you can use a simple
ordered dipped instead of beasts on and
you'll get many of the same benefits
beasts on serializes more things than in
order to [ __ ] will depending on what
you're doing and if you're using
something very flat like csv files on
the superclass for that thing is list
and you just treat everything as a list
or if you're going to use a dict reader
to read stuff out of you know csv files
then the superclass could be a plain old
[ __ ] it'll just be very flat but oh
yeah any one of those super classes is
good
absolutely you could manipulate a field
and produce garbage after you got it
from the database because the validation
only happens when we get it from the
database or just before we persist it so
yeah you could certainly reduce it to
garbage but you can add a valid a check
before the replace and then so the when
you write your own version replace or
make sure you do it all the time there's
no or add an explicit validate method is
a couple of things you could do to make
sure you hadn't make garbage out of it
along the way every single gets a little
tedious mostly because it's not very
fast and so you would you would pay a
huge penalty for that my preference is
if you're going to modify records and
there's some doubt in the back of your
mind that it may somehow break the
validation you really need to unit test
the willies out of that and not be
worrying about runtime the you need to
have a lot more confidence than just
runtime checks because if it breaks at
runtime you don't have any way to
diagnose it if you didn't have unit
tests to tell you what's broken so you
wind up having to go pretty back fri
down the road yes you often will wind up
having to put an extra attribute in
there like underscore class which has
the name of the class and that way when
you do a fine you take the class
attribute you say oh it's one of these
and and that's not not a bad hack the
the Java people do that all the time and
it doesn't bother them my preference is
that you shouldn't have too many
variations in a single collection in
[ __ ] world but sometimes you do and so
then you put an extra attribute in there
is a key to figure out what the type is
yeah anything else any other questions
on meta classes please don't ask yeah
the json validator will not allow you to
make a bad Python object because the
JSON representation is so very limited
as is beasts on in that it can only
really make dictionaries and lists and
it can only make dictionaries and lists
of a dozen or so primitive types and
eighty percent of your [ __ ] data is
going to be strings some will be
integers a few numbers and once in a
while a boolean here and there some
dates and things that you might want to
have converted a date time so any other
validation above and beyond the JSON
schema validation is unlikely to be
necessary I suppose you could have some
really sophisticated constraint that
needs to be implemented also but that
would be just you know another line of
code to make sure that this is always
twice that or some other kind of thing
that you can't express in JSON schema Oh
go back this was a better picture any
other questions yeah oh the update thing
what would have to happen with update is
you have an object and it has um uh the
the total a credit card so far this
month so you taking from some other
collection I've got a new credit card
transaction i'm going to add to this so
in Python world you know property you
know some object X dot balance plus
equals some amount you don't think twice
about it and so python is going to take
the old value of the balance at the
amount put it back in as an attribute in
there seamlessly silently and you don't
really have any record of what was
changed essentially you have a whole new
document then you can replace the entire
[ __ ] document but that sort of seems
silly because it was only a balance and
it was incremented so if you knew it was
being incremented you could have
generated a [ __ ] update one that says
on this document in this field increment
this property by this much and [ __ ]
would then do that update just that
add the document will be left in place
and it would be extremely fast but it's
difficult when you're assigning a
property value even if you have a
decorator to catch the property setter
you still don't know what changed was it
really an ad because you can't see the
rest of the expression that was going on
out there you could deduce that it was
an ad by doing a subtraction and saying
oh it must have been an end but maybe it
was a set we were just setting a new
value without doing arithmetic that
can't tell and so the update thing [ __ ]
gives you some power that doesn't
trivially get deduced by any class
definition because it would need to know
more about the application that a class
ever really knows because all it knows
is set and yet yes
you have um none of that because in the
no sequel database it's just a document
essentially a dictionary and so the
collection just has to hold dictionaries
that's it that's the only rule and the
you have one in [ __ ] you have one
mandatory field couch is similar
underscore ID and that's all you're
going to say and everything else is
completely on you and your application
to make sure that if I'm going to have a
property it has a consistent type and
you have to write all that your code
anyway so now the question is how can i
get that representation so that that
information is in exactly one place and
every different use case uses the one
and only definition but there's no
formal schema like there isn't sequel
where I declare a table and say that the
name column is a string of up to 64
characters [ __ ] i could put anything i
want in there maybe i ought to have a
property name name but there's no
practical limit on the size of the
strings that you can put in there so you
can't limit it to 64 and you don't need
to that a lot of the type definitions in
sequel world are old optimizations
because when I was young mmm and we're
talking a long time ago now when I was
young disc was slow and an i/o operation
forever and so you had to find a way to
do the least I owe you could get away
with so a lot of the schema definitions
in a sequel database are part of an old
optimization for old slow disks and a
lot of that isn't as helpful as it once
was
yeah that's why you have to write JSON
schema validators to be sure that data
that you're about to put in your
database really does fit whatever your
definition is and you have that
definition in exactly one place and in
my opinion not separate from the code
not in the database in the code so that
it's in the github repo and I like
having it in the class definition as
this JSON schema definition because the
JSON schema validator works really
really well that's the only way you can
do it you have it has to be in your code
and you have to be very disciplined
about using it consistently or you have
to impose that discipline from outside
and this class definition imposes that
discipline on you because go find my
class definition again because this this
class definition on this slide will not
create an instance unless it passes the
schema validation and this is the way
you make yourself very disciplined you
make it impossible to make an instance
of the class that doesn't pass the
validation yeah
yes the model so here's my external
financial services model and here's my
external financial services with
whenever vendor here's my external
financial services with whatever other
vendor but they're sharing the model
repo so that we have one and only one
and that way there's no arguing about
that yeah and especially if you have a
sort of a theoretical microservices
world I have all this flask container
that has everything in it but as a
practical matter I'm going to have a
second flask that X also access says
think I've got some bad jobs that live
outside flask or you know so the
theoretical microservices thing kind of
flakes out in reality and I better have
a separate model that I can import from
a variety of places thank you very much
I think we should get out of here